thank you so much for sitting down with
me today I love the movie so how are you
doing yeah thank you so much I'm doing
well thanks
so I noticed that you did a lot more
writing and and producing on TV shows
and stuff like that so and now this is
like a Netflix movie he talked about the
the collaborative process and and
transitioning to doing a directorial
debut for a Netflix movie like this yeah
I mean you know Aly and Randall and I
have known each other for a while so
that was super fun we had that short of
shorthand going in in terms of you know
the kind of story they wanted to tell
and the tone that we were going for and
so it was kind of an easy transition a
little bit because we knew each other
and then also like for me you know show
running and creating TV shows is kind of
similar in a way to directing a feature
film because it's it's kind of about
like world building and you know
introducing the tone and the characters
and everything like that so you know it
was a nice nice sort of segue in yeah
and with I interviewed the cast
previously before they say all set
because I asked them would you rather
have a director that gets too many notes
or not enough and they said that you've
kind of had the perfect balance of in
the middle it was like if you need it to
let them go but if you needed to say
something you would step in
so how was that like just with them
letting them letting them do improv
letting them feel the characters out how
did you go about doing that yeah well
it's so nice to hear yeah I mean you
know cuz you you want to leave room for
improv and any sort of like kind of
magic to happen on the day you know
you've got the script and everyone's
worked really hard so you want to make
sure you get what's on the page but then
it's also you know when you see it on
its feet and there's stuff that occurs
to people you want the freedom to be
creative you know you never want to
stifle that certainly in a comedy and
certainly when you're working with such
talented actors you know it'd be like a
waste like why would I not let Ally and
Randall and Daniel Achim and you know
Keanu and everybody you know improv and
I noticed like within this movie there
are a couple of different themes like
trying to go away from leaving home like
trying to figure out or do a lot of
different stuff like that can you tell
me like what the most important messages
you hope come across in this movie that
people take away whether it be like
don't be afraid to shoot your shot like
tell the person you love them
you love them like something like that
that's it you know and I think it's also
it's like don't be afraid junior shot
but also like don't be afraid to be who
you are
even within a relationship you know it's
like the two characters that Alan
Randall play there are each very
distinctive they have their own sort of
agenda and issues and it's okay to come
to get like one person doesn't have to
like become more submissive to the other
or give up or you sort of diminish
themselves so the other one can shine
it's like you both can shine and you
know I I feel like in 2019 like that's
the message I would love to get from my
rom-com you know yeah that's exactly
what it was and I told them earlier like
I love rom-coms I'm not the biggest fan
of him but by the end of the movie I was
sitting there I was like wait is this
what's going on right now yeah what I
truly enjoyed it and so do you have any
particular advice because there are a
lot of film students out there I know
Allie and M Randall both went to USC and
do you have any advice for like upcoming
aspiring directors or or showrunners for
who are trying to make it into the field
who might have their first feature
directorial debut I mean I would just
say I mean be is lucky you know if
you're lucky is I have to like work with
super talented people that's always a
bonus but you know just know what you
want you'll be very clear but don't be
so rigid to not allow other people to
contribute because I think if you have
the right partners creatively it'll just
elevate it and make it even better than
you know you thought it could be I mean
it's it's collaboration and you know you
definitely want a vision but you you
have to have room for fun and to improv
and play around and so what was the the
decision to bring Keanu Reeves and how
did that come about like what why did
I'll pick him out of like who like were
there any other considerations or was it
always we needed Keanu well I mean he
was like the dream you know it's like
that thing where it's like you're just
sort of like alright let's just put who
we don't know if this is possible
whatever we're just gonna put in like
who we would you know ideally loved and
then you know sent it to his agent and
then we heard that he read it and he
wanted to sit down so we met with him we
talked about the character he had so
many great funny ideas did a rewrite
sent it back and then he was like yeah I
want to do this and so you know we were
lucky to get him like in his
Wyck window hmm I think he like wrapped
like New York and was gonna go to
Morocco or something we had like the
five days yeah it's funny that's right
it's like riding the bike John we've
just came just just came out is what
like right in the way they're like
you're kind of giving them a little bit
of promo that y'all got it y'all created
a whole song for them and everything so
I thought that was cool and with that do
you have any particular so you've done
you've done the directorial debut now
you have any other would you rather do a
similar type of movie to this or for
your next project would you rather do
something completely different from this
in the future I feel like I mean it
would always have some elements of
comedy in it but I definitely think
maybe not a rom-com right away but
something that's interesting and the
same way that this was and just
unexpected I'm just looking for
something that you know that's
challenging and I've never done before
all right so I got a couple quick
questions for you four would you rather
are you down to play real quick I'm down
alright so would you rather your your
childhood crush tell you that they loved
you like super late or would you rather
just not not know at all like let's say
they like told you way too late like
what would you rather have what would I
still have a crush on them at this point
hmm maybe okay cuz you know if I did
I'll still have a crush I would not want
to know because that would ruin my life
you know exactly like wait a second I'm
trying to not be with this person but oh
wait they're back in the picture if I
didn't have a crush on them that would
want to know said like oh that's a sweet
like uh
I remember back in the day where I also
had a crush on you but now I've moved on
yeah so I'm not trying to ruin my life
you know so would you rather have would
you rather direct something that's an
original material or do something that
is already screen I mean adapted from
another source of material like a book
or something uh it's super depends like
I don't have a preference either way
like it just depends on the story
um and whether it's like compelling to
me or interesting and certainly
something I've never done before it's
always a big draw
alright so would you rather have a lot
of money and a short amount of time to
do filming or a short amount of money
and a lot of filming time to for your
project a lot of money in a short amount
of time cuz like well we'll get that
redbull going we'll work around the
clock yeah I mean
whatever we have money so we can afford
Red Bull alright and this is kind of
more of an actor side but I want to ask
you this as well because they all found
the other casts on this hilarious so
would you rather be asked to sneeze on
command or would you rather be asked to
cry on command I would rather be asked
to I would rather be asked to sneeze on
command because I feel like I just get
some pepper you know and just like make
myself sneeze or some like crying on
command would be rough idiot yeah cuz
you gotta get into it yeah yeah I don't
know how the actors do that I mean
there's there's a trick that the actors
use I don't know if they've told you
about it no they haven't it's like this
like this thing that blows in their eyes
yeah
so here's a little behind the scene you
know first actors won't tell you because
they're like oh yeah I'm so accesing my
emotion so easily that's not it thing so
it's like if we're in a scene and then
you're supposed to cry we'll be doing
the scene and then I'll have somebody
run in blow this thing in your eyes and
I'll take a second and then your eyes
will start tearing what yep that's it
and then I'll be like okay let's resume
just take it back to lines and then now
you're crying Wow
oh now I all right sound good sorry
actors sorry guys
thank you so much for sitting down with
me I love the movie I can't wait for
more people to see it thank you so much
as a pleasure thank you